joe biden back on the campaign trail in
delaware and
finally taking questions from the press
it comes as president trump looks to be
closing the polling gap
a new national poll finds the democratic
nominee's lead
narrowing by about five points since
june now keep in mind biden still
maintains his lead
and a separate poll shows biden
comfortably ahead earlier the former
vice president defended his campaign
strategy
he took some shots at president trump
take a look
i think uh my message is getting out
based on what the
all the polling data shows and the
millions of people who've watched what
i've had to say and the circumstance in
which i've said it
um but i would like to get out more
i've begun to prepare by uh by
going over what the president has said
multiple lies he's
he's told what i'd love to have is a
crawler at the bottom of the screen a
fact checker
president trump meanwhile responding
while he was holding a dueling campaign
event
in north carolina next year is going to
be one of the best economic years our
country's ever had
and i've seen that with the caveat
because
if he knows what he's doing which i
don't think biden wants to raise your
taxes
by three and four times it's crazy
dana uh let's talk politics uh the
national polling average right now has
biden up by about seven
i that's why i came to you uh biden
up by about seven percentage points
after the conventions
no change basically in most of the
battleground states
what do you make of all this well i do
think that there
is uh changes in the battleground states
and tightening
but i don't think you just have to look
at the polls to know that i think you
can look at
joe biden's activity you know when a
campaign
is starting to change its tactics and
strategy
that they have seen something in the
polls that either makes them concerned
or that they want to capitalize on
and in this case i think it's concern if
you think about it
the trump campaign has been on offense
and forcing joe biden and
doing a couple of things right he went
to pennsylvania to do that event
he took questions today he's going to go
to kenosha tomorrow so that is different
than even just three weeks ago
when they seemed very comfortable to try
to do this campaign by zoom that's not
going to work
uh joe biden taking questions today i
thought i did fine right it takes a
while to shake
out the cobwebs and start taking more
questions he should probably do a lot
more of that before the debates and
um that will probably that will probably
see if he can keep
the lead that he has but it is going to
tighten partisans always come home
the president is definitely putting his
uh
front foot forward i don't know is that
like a boxing thing probably
um he's on offense that's also
a sports term in case anybody didn't
know
and he is running away with the ball
i'll i'll leave it there nice
i think we got the message so jesse uh
their new ads out i don't know if you've
seen them but trump is sending a law and
order message
in his ads meanwhile biden is charging
trump with provoking violence and
failing to condemn
right wing white supremacist what do you
make of it do you think the ads are
going to move the needle
uh i do um but just before we get into
that one this race is tightening
lightning fast and it began in mid-july
when the president started holding his
coronavirus briefings again
started focusing on law and order
reopening schools and got some fresh
blood
in the campaign now biden looks really
defensive
he's scrambling following trump to
kenosha after saying he wouldn't do that
and now he's rushing out a panicked
45 million dollar ad buy to defend
himself against these law and order
attacks that have
absolutely evaporated his polling lead
in the battleground
states biden does not look comfortable
talking about this he wants to talk
about the virus
he does not want to be talking about
violence right now
he looks like he's shifting his message
back and forth for
first he sponsored the violence then he
ignored it then he blamed trump
for it the problem is this he botched
his sister soldier moment
he either is unwilling or unable to
stand up to the left-wing radical mob
and now he's losing suburban women
hispanics blacks
and business owners of all races because
of black lives matter and antifa
violence
the messaging from his campaign is
totally illogical if
if this is a riot why did you call it
peaceful all summer
if this was trump rioters why did you
bail them out
if you care so much about black lives
why did you say nothing about
50 people shot just now in chicago
and if trump is fanning the flames of
violence then why is he urging
democratic mayors and governors
to accept the national guard to stop the
violence
none of the things that biden has said
has made any sense people
see it and now it's registering
all right so greg uh what we know about
money
in politics is that it's really
important biden raised 364 million
in august breaking records you know his
favorability is up right now in the
pulse what do you make of the money we
don't know
how much president trump was able to
raise it is a lot of money but first i
do want to congratulate chris wallace
um after declining the offer to moderate
the debates
uh i wish their second choice all the
best i think he's going to do really
well if he wants to call
i have some tips for him um i was told
that joe's handlers told him the gap was
closing
and he got very depressed because that's
where he gets his pajamas
um and we made a big deal yesterday
about him
answering 131 questions what we left out
is that 84 of them were
what happened to your pants and the
remaining 47 is
why are they on your head can i just
point to a great tweet from donald trump
today and then i'll shut up this tweet
uh do we have it
this is a great tweet uh the dow jones
industrial just closed above twenty nine
thousand you were so lucky to have me as
your president
wink with joe hyden it would crash and
the alarming face this is an amazing
tweet it's got emojis
this is that he's breaking new ground
and he and by the way the natural
effortless way that he uses the emojis
contrasts that to the stiffness of joe
biden
when he tries to tweet you can tell it's
done by some flack who doesn't know what
day it is either
so i'm excited as you can tell i'll shut
up
that's all right i mean we i hadn't seen
that emoji that's interesting
hey emily uh you know a lot of this is
about
attracting suburban voters especially
suburban women so i looked at the
numbers and right now biden has a strong
lead maintaining it by 57 to 37
and in the suburbs overall not just
among women biden is up 58-35 so
what can the president do to improve his
standing with
suburban women well i think
what's interesting is the timing and the
surgeons and the trend
of that lead and really quickly i just
have to say that as greg was talking i
envisioned this future college course
of like presidential use of emojis and
students analyzing how
that's all that's all used um but i'll
just say this that to go back to the
timing and the trend that i think it's
pretty clear that after the convention
biden did not enjoy a bounce in the
polls and that's not atypical
but it seems also clear that trump did
and i think that sure going into labor
day there's always tightening of the
poles
but he enjoyed a solid performance at
the rnc and coupled with those law and
order issues in those battleground
states like wisconsin and minnesota that
are uniquely suited
for him i think it will be extremely
tight moving forward
and if he is able to pick off minnesota
then the entire democrats electoral map
will be thrown into chaos